yeah see this is why it's smart to
upload reviews of movies the week they
come out had I done that I'd have a
review for Gran Turismo for you this
week as it stands I'm like
in the words of Barry Burton from the
original Resident Evil what is this
we'll see if the YouTube algorithm gods
are pleased with this sacrifice of my
sanity
[Music]
so retro it's called retribution right
good news it is in fact retribution it's
a film in which
it's a film starring Liam Neeson in
which he gets in the car he's driving
his kids to school and then some bomber
calls a cell phone that's in his car and
he's like
and yeah he has to drive around do these
tasks for this bomber uh if he gets out
of the car there's a pressure plate the
bomb will blow up who doesn't do what he
says the bomb will blow up it's pretty
much the movie phone booth on wheels or
more claustrophobic version of speed
though it doesn't matter if it goes
above or below 50 that's not the reason
the bomb might blow up so I guess it's
just called speed limit you can already
tell I'm bitter and grumpy about this
movie so I'm not even going to save face
let's just do it Traditions are
Traditions I don't even know when this
became a tradition
but it is to me is it me or do my
thoughts get more concise the more I
drink Scotch on camera if not well give
me this one delusion all right first of
all Liam Neeson's weirdly cast in this
movie you see Liam Neeson like okay he's
gonna get on the phone with the guys be
like I have a particular set of skills
no it just feels like he's like
they haven't told me if I'm in Obi-Wan
season two yet I need this job but he
plays a Wall Street dad and early on
you're supposed to get the feeling this
guy's a [__] artist and someone
who's causing all these problems in his
life is really pissed at him and he
might have skeletons in the closet more
of a trickle that you're supposed to
experience because you already get the
vibe from this guy that's why Colin
Farrell and phone booth was perfect you
know this guy's a sleaze bag you know he
has skeletons in the closet pop the
popcorn we wait with baited breath man I
just started right in let's talk about
the positives first positives are
oh
sometimes
the movie reminded me of another movie
that it pulled from that did it better
in a weird roundabout way thinking of a
better movie while watching a bad movie
can be construed as a positive by your
brain the script in this movie well it
was kind of funny unintentionally so
this dude couple rows behind me it was
an empty theater it was me him I think a
family way up there this dude was just
laughing bless him example there's a
scene where he's trying to get in touch
with his wife people in this office are
giving him the stone wall so he has to
be like I need to talk to my wife the
kids are in danger so the wife gets on
the phone like hey how are the kids
what's wrong he was like you guys are
fine I just had to get you on the phone
we're in a car with a bomb it's an odd
way of saying the kids are fine I feel
like the phrase is either the kids are
fine or they're in a car with a bomb
what's your definition of find their dad
of the year I suppose it's a little
thing but there are so many little
things in here world where Devil's in
the details there's so many moments
where I was like
I it's hard to talk about because a lot
of the [__] in the movie is wrapped
into spoilers I've seen that a lot in
movies you can almost feel the
screenwriters being like but
if we have a lot of the contradictions
and the [__] wrapped into spoilers
and people who review the movie can't
talk about that
boom that's a thing though here I am
Scotch at hand
and I don't give a [__] so I'm going to
talk about it spoiler alert I know we're
kind of breaking protocol but don't care
I'm telling you I've seen the movie it's
not worth caring about what's the over
under Blue Beetle makes more than this
movie this weekend right exactly it
doesn't matter I'm not gonna tell you
everything I'm not gonna tell you the
big scheme the big plan the who the why
you know what you need to know the
movie's not good you should skip it
entirely great all right let's have a
little fun here and talking about some
of the [__] that's kind of wrapped
into spoilers there's a scene where he's
at a dead stop all the police have
surrounded him this is actually the
scene the movie got
far more interesting it is a subject of
much interest when thinking about the
film
as much as I'm going to pre-review after
this review I'm never thinking about the
movie again but when thinking about the
film before I go on camera I'm like yeah
this was the most interesting part of
the movie is when the car stopped moving
and he's talking with the cops and the
cops are like yeah this cop lady is like
I don't believe you he's like there's a
bomb under my seat she's like that's
very quantifiable you is there
still think you're the one doing it sir
who's clearly doing this under duress
and he's like he's been calling me from
this phone she's like that's the phone
he's like yes I don't know why am I late
that's my Liam Neeson voice that's as
good as I get I don't know this is the
phone here take this phone go elsewhere
he might call you on it then you'll know
or you can just triangulate the position
of whatever phone there are a hundred
things you could do with this phone if I
just give it to you I'll stay down here
where there's no cell phone signal and
he can't detonate the bomb the only
thing that can detonate the bomb is if I
get up and I'll wait it's fine so anyhow
after the cops are like yeah you're on a
pressure plate and there's a bomb
attached to that I kind of don't believe
you though why don't you really tell the
truth he hauls ass he takes off the cops
chase him and it feels it's like he just
goes around the corner and the cops are
like
where'd he go I don't know it's
he was right here I
because then he parks and has a 10
minute conversation with the bomber that
just made no sense it's like where are
the cops they were just on your ass you
have a very recognizable car with no
doors at this point why are they not
there right now at a point the car tips
on its side still doesn't blow up the
car in which he's sitting on a pressure
plate is on its side in which he is not
applying the correct amount of pressure
to keep that bomb from going off still
hasn't gone off you ever weigh yourself
on a scale sideways doesn't really work
then he falls in a river the car does
finally blow up and the cop who is
suspecting him the whole time is like
the car blew up and he's safe in the
river in fact that's the fishiest thing
I've seen from this suspect yet I I
should be like that's definitely our guy
but
I think I believe him now not of
approval to end credits that's where the
movie ends definitely what we used to
call mow movie of the week the movie's
just boring it's as simple as that but
if the shoe fits
actually
this is important man you ever hear a
phrase in a totally otherwise terrible
script and just kind of weirdly blows
your mind
it shouldn't but it does there's a line
in this movie where someone says in
Cinderella if the slipper fits so
perfectly then why did it fall off I was
like
um
oh
I don't know
but having to think about that that's
kind of a rabbit hole back to the point
that got me on that tangent if the shoe
fits and the shoe of Retribution fits to
be dog [__] alright so Barbie have you
seen it what did you think about it just
playing the odds folks who are we
kidding or retribution or any
made-for-tv movie that got a theatrical
release have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]